yeah welcome to a new video five-minute
game playing efore again for a change
you have an open Sicilian now on the
dragon playing them this position line
because I don't know the more aggressive
mainline kawin see eight this was played
as usual super quickly no idea
uh-huh is this a way you can play this
interesting
yeah 195 analysis makes quincy eight and
look the eight look a bit strange i
think if you need to take now amia
cannot really take
and not quite sure what blacks movers
really so it looks looks a bit a bit
strange
yeah needs to
okay can go here my 7 is very weak but I
cannot them cannot use this at the
moment
and yeah I wonder about c4 c4 Knight
takes rook c1b 594 look sir looks quite
quite problematic yeah maybe it is still
okay
and is he threatening to play to play
Knights you form
hmm not sure come on let's let's do this
I'm not not sure it's the desirable move
protecting this this pawn
I was amazed how quickly this is the
stuff is played but okay it's probably
just me playing the the most committal
move instantly okay so knight c6 was
Maya force my IDM and runs got a six
yeah probably it is all right with the
just playing quickly I could take be 50
wait what about b3 even be three and
Bishop takes p5
and yeah looks like wow thick quite a
quite a funny position so knight c6 will
be 8
threatening queen before
I'm not threatening it may be but given
I thought 96 what would be good taking
e7d 85
also cannot play ecigs da desire hanging
tries yeah you cannot play it but he
plays it it's typical um okay mmm I with
the poor with the bishop
yeah it's a bit bit strange all this
rocks the aid of the the strange move
might just take place instantly just
ok
God storm Sally fairly solid I need to
get rid of this this piece it's really a
nuisance we should be towards the idea
yeah I'm willing to to return and
exchange maybe
this is just a passive I mean no way
yeah it's um it's am still a bit tricky
in a blitz game it still has some some
play
yeah but I can play Queenie eight again
next smooth and this is always tied to
this and I want I want a 45 at some
point I can exchange sec the exchange
probably when the apron is fired once
enough cannot really move something
great iam
check-check
Queen a 75 now come on let's give it
back don't mind yeah the a bonus is with
my winner anyway oops
and the beep on
I'm down to nine seconds I only see this
now
check
aww
draw Alfred
oh that's a rare yeah I somehow I even
lost time here for what exactly I was
just just one or two seconds every move
so that I didn't didn't manage to to win
this at the end yeah this is of course
just just over it should be four and
resins but we should be for King c3 and
King just just just easy I can also take
h5 of course now I can even manage eight
seconds my okay I lost a bit of a lost
my nerve see a bit too to take him now
okay I was just just spending spending
too much time before otherwise I think
it was pretty pretty okay this game yeah
thanks for watching